Irma's already devastated a string of
islands in the Caribbean
at least ten people there have died
thousands more are homeless
Tony de copal is in Puerto Rico tracking
Armas impact Tony good morning good
morning more than half the homes here
are without power and many areas like
clean drinking water as well but overall
Puerto Rico counts itself lucky as
images of devastation roll in from
islands less than a day's boat ride to
the east or the west where Hurricane
Irma
menaced the islands of Turks and Caicos
overnight the howling winds and heavy
rains of Irma battered the islands of
Turks and Caicos overnight it's believed
to be the first category 5 hurricane to
hit the island chain we are stuck in
this hurricane vacationers like Cynthia
McCall are trapped on the islands and
don't know when they'll be able to get
home it's mother nature you have no idea
what's gonna happen and then we looked
at the pictures of the devastation in
Barbuda and said Martin this Lake my god
is that what's gonna happen us east of
Turks and Caicos the northern Leeward
Islands received her master August punch
Saint Martin was socked the Dutch prime
minister says parts of the island are
without power and water describing the
damage as wide-scale destruction
officials believe about 6,000 Americans
are still trapped on the island at least
four people are confirmed dead and 50
injured the entire housing stock was
damaged and on Barbuda a tiny island of
just over 60 square miles
nearly every building was damaged
leaving 60% of the people homeless
rescue workers across the Caribbean are
rushing to get food and fresh water to
island residents and only then can they
fully assess the damage and begin the
long cleanup Jeff Tony thank you very
much